en application du cinquième alinéa de
l'article 13 de la Constitution et de la
loi organique du 23 juillet 2010 nous
allons entendre monsieur Sylvain
vaserman que le Président de la
République envisage de nommer aux
fonctions de président du conseil
d'administration de l'Agence de la
transition écologique monsieur vaserman
monsieur le Président je vous souhaite
la bienvenue dans notre commission et
dans ces lieux que vous connaissez
parfaitement pour avoir été membre très
actif et j'insiste sur le terme très
actif de notre assemblée dont vous avez
présidé de nombreuses séances
je rappelle la procédure dont vous êtes
familier l'audition d'aujourd'hui qui
est public
sera suivi dans votre par
scrutin secret effectué par appel
nominal et or la présence de la personne
auditionnée et aucune délégation de vote
ne sera possible un point très important
chers collègues parce que je pense que
je vais recevoir quelques messages sur
ce point là précisément le dépouillement
du scrutin aura lieu non pas aujourd'hui
mais la semaine prochaine le mercredi 5
juillet en fin de matinée après que
Monsieur vaserman aura été entendu par
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
du Sénat comme le prévoit notre
règlement nous avons nommé un rapporteur
sur cette proposition de nomination
Monsieur David topiac merci pour le
travail il a élaboré pour notre
commission un questionnaire qui a été
préalablement envoyé à Monsieur vaserman
dont les réponses vous ont été diffusés
je donne sans plus tarder la parole à
notre rapporteur monsieur topiac et puis
nous entendons par la suite monsieur
vaserman monsieur rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur vaserman après deux
premières auditions qui n'ont pas permis
de reconfirmer votre prédécesseur la
tête de l'ADEME nous sommes à nouveau
réunis aujourd'hui pour étudier et nous
prononcer sur votre candidature à la
présidente du conseil d'administration
de l'ADEME sur le fondement de l'article
13 de la Constitution
si l'exercice nous est devenu familier
l'enjeu reste très important l'ADEM est
une agence essentielle pour le pilotage
des politiques et des actions à mener en
faveur de la transition écologique la
nomination de son président nous incobe
et nous honorent
vous avez proposé votre candidature tout
juste un an après avoir cessé votre
activité de député certains nombre
d'entre nous vous ont connu dans vos
anciennes fonctions de députés de
vice-président de l'Assemblée nationale
vous indiquez naturellement être
intéressé par les sujets liés à
l'énergie à la transition écologique et
une partie de votre expérience
professionnelle ainsi que votre
expérience en tant qu'élutant national
que local le prouve je rappelle comme
vous l'avez indiqué dans votre
curriculum vitae que vous avez été
pendant 9 ans à la tête d'un réseau
local de gaz le réseau de gaz de
Strasbourg et que c'est essentiellement
à cette occasion que vous avez pu
observer le fonctionnement de l'ADEME et
à mettre un interlocuteur
je précise que l'ADN en 2023 disposait
d'un budget de plus de 4,2 milliards
d'euros en intégrant le financement du
programme France 2030 il s'agit d'un des
premiers opérateurs de l'État et ses
missions sont de plus en plus
diversifiées
nous avons pu prendre connaissance de
vos réponses questionnaire que je vous
avais transmis préalablement et je vous
remercie d'avoir apporté votre vision et
des précisions je rends complément trois
petites questions la première au moins
un des quatre scénarii que la dame
propose dans ce rapport de prospective
transition 2050 repose sur un usage
important de nouvelles technologies
vertes pensez-vous que le scénario qui
reposerait uniquement sur une évolution
des technologies nous permettrait
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone en
deuxièmement comme vous le soulignez il
n'y a pas de transition énergétique sans
les territoires malheureusement de
nombreux PC aet sont un désérance faute
de moyens sur des territoires obligés
volontaires pour cette démarche
vertueuse en transition énergétique
comptez-vous pérenniser développer
l'aide en ingénierie des territoires
proposés
notamment dans le cadre des contrats
d'objectifs territoriaux
enfin je vous serez reconnaissant de
nous préciser ce que vous allez faire
concernant les engagements
professionnels que vous avez
actuellement je laisse à mes collègues
députés le soin de vous interroger
davantage sur votre candidature je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur
le Président merci monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs bonjour à toutes
et à tous c'est avec humilité mais avec
beaucoup de détermination je suis là
aujourd'hui et j'aimerais aborder ce que
ce que je traitais dans mon
questionnaire à savoir et essayer de
répondre très brièvement à trois
questions en quoi mon expérience
est-elle légitime pour postuler à cette
exigeante responsabilité de la présence
de l'ADEME quelle est ma vision pour la
dame et ce que je peux dire des missions
d'émissions actuelles
le premier point sur mon parcours je
voulais simplement reprendre
une tribune qui a été publiée très
récemment que j'ai découvert comme
peut-être comme vous dans le JDD c'était
des ONG qu'il avait signé un ami Kelly
madame Falco monsieur frftri monsieur
Blondeau et Monsieur Arthus-Bertrand et
qui identifiait selon eux quatre
critères importants pour le prochain
président de l'ADEME et je les partage
parce que ils m'ont ils m'ont surpris
agréablement le premier critère était
d'avoir une d'être un politique et pas
un technocrate d'avoir une expérience
d'élus locale et nationale évidemment
j'étais mère de village pendant 10 ans
présidente petites comme vice-présidente
plus grande comme com et lui régional je
suis très attaché à ce que j'ai appris
pendant ces mandat locaux
et puis le National ça a beaucoup
d'entre vous le savent ici au nom d'un
dernier le deuxième critère qu'ils
identifiait c'est d'être d'avoir été
d'avoir eu un parcours en entreprise
alors toute ma vie à part 5 ans du
dernier mandat ont été dans le monde
économique entreprise privée ou
entreprise publique que j'ai dirigé
pendant pendant 8 ans qui est réseau GDS
on parlerait dans un instant mais ce
parcours d'entreprise il est important
parce que l'ADEME est emprise avec le
monde économique avec des raisonnements
économiques de business plan et de et de
rentabilité avec des enjeux évidemment
majeurs sur le carbone on en parlera
dans un instant et puis troisième point
troisième critère qu'ils identifiait
avoir déjà travaillé avec l'ADEME et
pour ça je voudrais simplement partager
une chose qui est très factuelle quand
je suis arrivé chez réseau GDS c'est une
entreprise qui depuis 150 ans donc cette
entreprise de gaz filiale de la ville de
Strasbourg qui puisse 150 ans faisait du
gaz naturel
quand j'en suis parti 30% du chiffre
d'affaires 30% du chiffre d'affaires et
aujourd'hui
50% donc c'est un mouvement pérenne
était sur les réseaux de chaleur sur
trois domaines principalement les
réseaux de chaleur et c'est là que j'ai
commencé à travailler avec la DMC là que
j'ai vu que sans la dame ces réseaux de
chaleur ne verrait pas le jour
donc les réseaux de chaleur deuxième
point le biométhane on a été les
premiers à injecter du biométhane depuis
une station d'épuration dans les réseaux
et troisième point les contrats de
performance énergétiques j'y reviendrai
parce qu'il y a un point important que
vous avez voté il y a quelques quelques
mois sur le sujet en tout cas 30% de ce
chiffre d'affaires sur l'ADEME c'est
repartance sur les réseaux de chaleur
c'est là où j'ai découvert travaillé
avec l'ADEME travailler avec eux sur des
choses extrêmement concrètes les
business plan qui doit être ni trop
profitable ni pas assez la mesure de
l'impact sur les réseaux de chaleur
c'est des réseaux de chaleur de de
biomasse en l'occurrence avec le réseau
le plus vert du Grand Est à l'époque
le troisième critère qu'ils identifie
donc c'était d'avoir travaillé avec la
dame et le 4e c'est les convictions et
la vision qu'on peut avoir sur la
transition énergétique et là j'ai envie
de dire ma première conviction c'est ça
alors qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ça
c'est un livre blanc que j'ai écrit en
2016 donc ça date pas d'hier qui
s'appelle le modèle territorial de
l'énergie un accélérateur de la
transition énergétique parce que j'ai la
conviction et ça date pas d'hier et je
l'ai s'adapte pas de ma préparation à
cet orale aujourd'hui j'ai la conviction
que c'est par les territoires qu'on
réussit la transition énergétique
les cadres que vous votez ici sont
évidemment fondamentaux il y a aucun
doute mais qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un
porteur de projet va prendre le projet
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un projet de
biométhane va avoir l'acceptabilité
citoyenne et j'en ai vu réussir j'en ai
vu échouer qu'est-ce qu'il va faire que
les élus locaux sont mains dans la main
avec les acteurs économiques pour
essayer de construire un modèle qui
permet d'aboutir à une solution de
réseau de chaleur ou autre et ça ces
projets il naissent ils réussissent où
ils échouent sur les territoires et ça
je crois que c'est un point absolument
majeur en tout cas une conviction
absolument majeure que j'aimerais que
j'aimerais partager
deuxième point concerne la vision que je
peux avoir pour la dame alors je vais
vous le dire très clairement
ce serait présomptueux sans avoir jamais
mis les pieds réellement à la dame
travailler avec eux certes mais sans
avoir mis les pieds alors qu'il y a des
femmes et des hommes qui travaillent
depuis des décennies seraient présente
tu d'être là face à vous en disant voilà
ce qu'il faut faire pour les cinq années
à venir pour l'ADEME
en revanche en revanche j'aimerais
partager trois points de réflexion qui
me semblent important
d'abord je dois prendre un engagement
clair si vous me choisissez si vous me
confiez cette responsabilité la première
chose que je ferais c'est un tour des
régions
pourquoi parce que l'ADEME a un contrat
d'objectif et de performance à
renégocier et qu'il me semblait
essentiel d'entendre d'écouter les
territoires alors c'est quoi
spécifiquement les élus territoriaux les
préfets qui depuis la loi 3DS ont un
rôle particulier et évidemment les
femmes et les hommes qui travaillent à
la dame je crois que ce Tour de France
en prenant les 13 régions de métropoles
en prenant une un territoire d'outre-mer
j'aimerais boucler ce Tour de France
pour fin septembre et donc commencer
commencer par avoir cette vue des
territoires alors je dis fin septembre
je vais prendre peut-être 15 jours de de
battements ou de marge c'est parce que
les agendas sont parfois durs à
coordonner entre les préfets les
présidents de région les vice-président
en charge développement économique les
élus territoriaux mais je crois que
c'est important parce que comment
pourrait-on négocier un contrat
d'objectifs et de performance sans avoir
écouté d'abord ceux qui vivent
ressentent comprennent la dame au
quotidien
et je vais prendre un deuxième
engagement très clair
j'ai échangé avec beaucoup d'entre vous
et je vous remercie pour le temps que
vous m'avez consacré avant cette réunion
à peu près personne ne connaissait son
directeur régional de l'ADEME à peu près
personne évidemment certains le
connaissent je veux pas généraliser mais
je pense qu'il est essentiel que tous
les ans les directeurs de la dame
invitent l'ensemble des parlementaires
parce que les budgets que vous votez à
Paris se traduisent concrètement sur les
territoires et rendre compte au dernier
kilomètre de la façon dont ces budgets
se traduisent dans des projets dans des
réseaux de chaleur dans des avec des
femmes et des hommes qui s'y impliquent
concrètement c'est à mon avis essentiel
et ça participera du lien qu'on doit
créer entre les parlementaires et
l'ADEME donc je crois que c'est un point
extrêmement important sur lequel je
voulais que je voulais que je voulais
préciser
sur cette sur cette vision donc je
voudrais simplement partager trois axes
de réflexion la première il y a un
indicateur que je verbalise comme ça et
que j'aime beaucoup qui est l'efficacité
carbone de l'euro investi tout ça c'est
de l'argent public ce qu'on doit voir
c'est son efficacité carbone
c'est-à-dire quand j'injecte un million
d'euros à la dame combien de tonnes de
carbone j'économise il se trouve que
maintenant on a des objectifs clairs 400
millions de tonnes aujourd'hui 270
millions pour 2030 donc on a ces
objectifs chiffrés encore faut-il que
nos raisonnements nos façons d'échanger
nos mesures mettre en avant cette
efficacité carbone de l'euro investie et
je crois que c'est un premier point sur
lequel je pense il faudra travailler
pour avoir un niveau de dialogue et et
puis d'ailleurs quand on parle avec
Bercy je crois que l'essentiel c'est
aussi de dire mais si vous avez un
million à mettre sur la transition
énergétique voilà voilà le nombre de
tonnes de carbone qu'on peut traduire
dans ce million d'euros donc je crois
que avec vous qui votez les budgets avec
avec les ministères je crois que c'est
important d'avoir un peut-être un nouvel
étalon sur l'efficacité carbone de
l'argent public investi le deuxième
point un point qui m'a semblé évident
quand je l'ai pratique quand les
pratiquais c'est la nécessaire
coordination et je répondrai du coup à
votre question monsieur le rapporteur
sur le sujet entre les bras armés de la
puissance publique et de l'État sur le
territoire je cite notamment la NCT le
serema et l'ADEME
préalablement à cette réunion j'ai
appelé deux personnes pour pour voir si
l'intuition que j'avais était correcte
le premier c'est le directeur général
délégué par intérim actuel de l'ADEME le
deuxième c'est le directeur général
adjoint du serema et et l'idée que je
propose c'est très simple c'est d'abord
d'institution
d'institutionnaliser de mettre en place
un dialogue concret entre les patrons de
ces entités sur les territoires
aujourd'hui si étrange ça disparaisse ça
n'existe pas ou en tout cas c'est
hétérogène
pour autant notre responsabilité en tant
que la responsabilité des acteurs
publics c'est bien de veiller à ce qui
est pas de redondance une optimisation
le soutien collectivité ça va être et
j'y viens un point essentiel donc ce
coordonné dans l'action des acteurs
publics et de l'argent public investi
c'est la moindre des choses qu'on doit
au budget qui sont qui sont qui sont
consentis et aux collectivités
auxquelles auxquelles on est on est en
soutien donc voilà donc je pense très
concrètement avoir un courrier signé des
patrons de ces entités vers tous les
directeurs régionaux en disant
dorénavant d'abord je pense qu'il faut
une première réunion très formelle sur
les points positifs et les points
d'amélioration sur le terrain et
deuxième point de l'institutionnaliser
tous les ans et puis troisième point je
voudrais dire je sais que vous en êtes
conscient parce que j'ai eu beaucoup de
retour sur le sujet
l'expertise de l'ADEME les femmes et les
hommes de l'ADEME ont une expertise
internationale reconnue je veux pas dire
que c'est unique au monde mais c'est une
expertise et une richesse d'expertise
qui est qui est incroyable en réalité et
qui est reconnu nationalement et
internationalement et ça c'est une
chance et j'en viens à la mission à la
mission de la dame pour moi il y a deux
missions principales la première c'est
d'éclairer la décision publique de
l'inspirer et de l'éclairer et pour ça
ces femmes et ces hommes qui depuis des
années développent cette expertise sont
évidemment le premier atout c'est vrai
au niveau national et c'est vrai au
niveau local le défi que nous avons sur
les territoires pour les collectivités
locales c'est l'ingénierie je prends
deux petits exemples rapides on parle
souvent du chantier du siècle en parlant
de la rénovation des 400 millions de
mètres carrés de bâtiments publics à
rénover ou à décarboner c'est un
chantier immense
et vous avez voté une noix il y a
quelques mois quasiment à l'unanimité
pour permettre aux collectivités d'avoir
une arme en plus de face à cette immense
chantier cet immense défi qui est la
possibilité de faire des contrats de
performance énergétiques c'est une bonne
idée globalement un acteur tiers prend
du financement rénov des bâtiments ou
gère une équation carbone et grosso modo
pour un budget constant en tout cas un
budget prévisible qui assume la
collectivité ça permet de rembourser les
travaux par les économies générées
j'ai eu dans ma vie la chance de faire
un contrat de performance énergétique
avec un bailleur social 900 logements
quartiers du viral à Strasbourg j'ai vu
la complexité de ces mécanismes mais
j'ai vu leur intérêt aussi et l'ouvrir
aujourd'hui au collectivités
territoriales ce qui n'était pas
possible à l'époque ça ouvre un champ
sur lequel croyez-moi l'expertise est
indispensable pour pas tomber dans les
écueils des PPP pour pour avoir le pour
avoir de la part de l'ADEME je crois que
la dame et le l'acteur essentiel pour ça
un soutien à l'ingénierie pour que des
collectivités taille moyenne en
particulier puissent bénéficier de ces
outils avec un cadre serein stabilisé et
éclair
et puis enfin le deuxième rôle majeur
c'est évidemment l'optimisation de
l'investissement et de l'argent public
qui lui est confiait avec cette cette
efficacité carbone comme j'ai pu le dire
de des 0 investi des zéro d'argent
public investi avec avec la vitesse
d'exécution et je crois que je crois que
sur ce sujet là
on a je voudrais terminer en répondant
par la première des questions que vous
avez posé monsieur le monsieur le
rapporteur sur les scénarios
c'est d'abord un message d'espoir que je
vous ai donné parce que les solutions
existent et de nouvelles s'inventent
tous les jours et que le rôle de la dame
c'est pas de faire les choix
et finalement peu importe la vie d'un
président de l'ADEME d'un ingénieur de
la dame son rôle c'est d'éclairer
d'inspirer parfois la décision publique
au niveau national bien sûr avec les
expertise qu'ils peuvent apporter au
niveau local aussi en accompagnement
d'ingénierie et cette mission là elle me
semble extrêmement importante dans les
années à venir comme j'ai pu le dire sur
le sur les territoires les solutions
existent je vais prendre un exemple j'ai
échangé avec beaucoup de responsables de
filières ces dernières semaines filières
solaires filières biomasse filière
filière géothermie
par exemple la géothermie de surface
représente un enjeu important on parle
maintenant de géostockage on a des
solutions qu'on peut déployer sur
lesquels sur lesquels je crois je suis
un peu marcher sur lesquels je crois
l'ADEME a un rôle majeur pour répandre
généraliser massifier on dit parfois ces
technologies là et expérimenter sur les
nouvelles technologies qui arrivent
et je réponds à la troisième des
questions que vous avez posé j'ai
aujourd'hui une activité de conseils de
consulting l'un des contrats s'arrête
fin juin les deux autres je les
arrêterai évidemment enfin ça va sans
dire mais ça va mieux en le disant je
les arrêterai évidemment c'est toute
activité professionnelle si vous me
choisissez et que vous me faites la
confiance de me confier ces mandats je
dois dire que j'ai saisi la Haute
autorité pour faire un détail absolument
complet de l'ensemble des contrats que
je peux avoir aujourd'hui et évidemment
je suis vrai m'intégralité de leur
recommandations monsieur le Président
Monsieur de rapporteur merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs merci pour votre
écoute
merci monsieur vaserman nous en venons à
la liste des orateurs orateurs des
groupes et pour le groupe Renaissance la
parole est à Marjolaine meunier millefer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur mes chers collègues cher
Sylvain quel plaisir de vous retrouver à
l'Assemblée nationale merci pour ce
propos liminaire très clair et ambitieux
alors vous n'en avez pas parlé encore
mais ici nous nous souvenons avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasme de votre travail
sur la démocratie et le rapport aux
citoyens votre test sur le sujet alors
que au sujet sur nos banc était que de
plus en plus les citoyens veulent des
circuits courts entre eux et les
décisions publiques et ça ça change
profondément le rôle des élus qui
doivent pleinement intégrer cette
nouvelle donne et dans deux ouvrages sur
le sujet et une proposition de
résolution qui avait emporté largement
l'adhésion de l'Assemblée vous
identifier des pistes d'implication des
citoyens alors avec cette expertise et
un moment où la transition écologique
doit faire face à la réticence ou à
l'impatience de nos concitoyens comment
pensez-vous que l'ADEME puisse se
rapprocher des gens et contribuer
davantage à l'acceptabilité de la mise
en oeuvre des solutions nécessaires
vous avez mentionné en revanche votre
travail comme directeur général de
réseau de gaz vous avez expliqué que
vous avez piloté le revertissement et le
développement du réseau de chaleur pour
faire le quatrième plus gros réseau
français quand même et vous avez écrit
alors un livre blanc sur une vision très
téréeux territorialité de la transition
écologique alors c'est un autre sujet
évidemment où nous nous sommes très
attachés aussi la place des élus locaux
et des territoires dans la planification
écologique mais je fais un peu
d'archéologie j'ai retrouvé un article
de l'époque sur le sujet qui commence
comme ça je cite entre l'électricien et
le gazier historique le vainqueur est
les deux plutôt que de concourir l'un
contre l'autre à la délégation de
service public de réseau de chaleur de
quartier les
hérités de l'électricité de Strasbourg
et de gaz de Strasbourg ont réuni leurs
compétences dans une même offre qu'il a
emporté auprès de l'euro métropole alors
bravo pour ça parce que ça montre que
vous avez également c'est un homme de
négociation et de compromis ambitieux ce
qui sera pas inutile dans vos nouvelles
fonctions le groupe Renaissance
accueille aussi avec beaucoup d'intérêt
votre proposition de renforcer les
interactions de l'ADEME avec les forces
vives des territoires via ses directions
régionales et avec les autres agences
publiques que sont le céréma l'ANA le
CSTB linect ou encore les agences de
l'eau alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser comment vous voyez ces
interactions j'ai un petit point de
vigilance monsieur wazerman sur votre
volonté de baser vos décisions de
l'agence sur l'efficacité carbone de
l'euro investie on se constate que
parfois ça vient soutenir des solutions
qui sont déjà matures et ça vient moins
soutenir l'innovation or la dame est
vraiment une agence d'innovation et
effectivement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous montrer comment ça va soutenir ça
malgré tout et c'est trop court monsieur
le Président deux minutes pour
accueillir un collègue sur ce sujet mais
pour toutes ces raisons et pour d'autres
le groupe Renaissance votera sans
réserve en faveur de votre nomination
merci et forcément puisque la première
prise de parole est à deux minutes 22
les autres collègues pourront parler 2
minutes 22 il y a aucune difficulté
pour le groupe rassemblement national la
parole est à Emmanuelle bléri oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur vaserman
dans un premier temps laissez-moi quand
vous saluer vis-à-vis de la démarche que
vous avez faite auprès de des
parlementaires
c'était très intéressant de discuter
avec vous j'allais dire en amont de
cette réunion aujourd'hui qui est la
réelle réunion pour vous nommer
éventuellement j'aimerais aussi vous
rappeler pourquoi on a et c'est très
important pourquoi on a refusé pourquoi
on a rejeté la nomination de Monsieur le
Maire de Charles de Mézières pour
plusieurs raisons en considère qu'avec
un budget qui a donc doublé en 2023
concernant la dame on ne peut pas être
effectivement maire d'une commune
d'environ 50 000 habitants présidents de
la métropole et gérer l'ADEME ça c'est
juste pas possible c'est à dire que le
territoire a besoin de proximité vous
l'avez dit vous engagez à faire un tour
des régions c'est très important
on considère que la transition
écologique ne peut se faire que dans un
cadre apaisé et non coercitif et non
punitif et pour se faire effectivement
il serait intéressant je le souligne je
trouve ça même Rome plutôt remarquable
il sera important effectivement de
rencontrer nos élus locaux
je le dis aussi on n'a pas la science
infuse dans ce domaine on n'a pas la
science infuse et je considère et le
groupe rationnel considère qu'on peut
encore évoluer et vous allez me dire oui
mais c'est pas mon rôle effectivement de
d'avoir une position politique mais
quand même vous avez dépenser le demi
public donc quand on dépense des publics
on a quand même une vision un peu
finalement politique de l'ensemble au
sens noble du terme j'entends
et puis pour reprendre un petit peu une
citation de Saint-Exupéry on est député
vous êtes
président de l'ADEME en tout cas vous
êtes proposé pour être pour la
présidence
on n'a pas la science infuse je disais
et chacun est seul responsable de tout
sur la matière voilà donc ça veut dire
que on compte aussi sur vous plus tard
si vous êtes nommé pour nous faire aussi
des retours parce que les parlementaires
ont besoin d'avoir des retours concrets
et pour tout vous dire à l'heure
actuelle il est 10h03 on n'a pas fait
notre choix on va attendre les échanges
parce que nous sommes ouverts aux
échanges au dialogues et puis nous
prendrons notre décision je vous
remercie
merci pour le groupe la France insoumise
nue pèse la parole est à Aymeric Caron
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
vaserman bonjour
l'ADEME est un acteur important de la
transition souhaitable et indispensable
vers une société écologique et ses
champs de compétences en nombreux
gestion des déchets préservation des
sols qualité de l'air lutte contre le
bruit efficace énergétique promotion des
énergies renouvelables des sujets qui
impact évidemment le quotidien de toutes
les Françaises et les français s'il vous
plaît juste est-ce qu'on peut écouter
s'il vous plaît merci merci je vous en
prime monsieur quand
l'ADEME publie des rapports très
intéressants comme celui qui expliquait
en 2015 que la France pourrait dès 2050
avoir une électricité fournie à 100% par
les énergies renouvelables sans que ça
coûte plus cher que de maintenir le
nucléaire à 50% du mix ou encore ce
rapport de 2001 de sur les scénarios
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone qui
préconise une réduction drastique de la
consommation de viande voilà de la part
de la den des pistes très raisonnables
qu'on ne peut qu'encourager la question
qui nous est posée ce matin monsieur
vazerman et celle de votre engagement
passé sur tous les sujets que je viens
brièvement d'évoquer or votre parcours
professionnel politique ne nous permet
pas vraiment d'identifier avec clarté
les preuves de votre implication à ce
jour pour l'écologie et la défense du
vivant ça nous gêne un petit peu parce
qu'on voudrait pas ce matin cautionner
malgré nous la nouvelle manifestation
d'un phénomène auquel Emmanuel Macron
nous habitué à savoir le simple recazage
d'un ancien élu ou ministre à qui il
faudrait trouver une fonction nouvelle
nous n'affirmons évidemment pas que
c'est le cas qui vous concerne
nous nous aurions pas vous faire ce
reproche évidemment mais on a simplement
besoin de mieux comprendre à ma question
sera simple sur le site de l'ADEME on
trouve ce sondage mis en exergue 58% des
Français
pensent qu'il faudra modifier de façon
importante nos modes de vie pour limiter
le changement climatique
modifier de façon importante son mode de
vie c'est pas simplement faire la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments ou se
mettre à l'électricité verte même si
évidemment c'est indispensable mais ça
ne change pas vraiment nos modes de vie
est-ce que vous aussi vous préconisez
déjà on vous fiant sur vos votre
expérience et vos compétences des
changements majeurs dans nos
comportements pour limiter le changement
climatique et si oui lesquels et est-ce
que vous-même dans votre vie personnelle
vous avez initié certains changements
ces dernières années pour être un acteur
de la lutte contre le changement
climatique
merci Monsieur Caron pour le groupe les
républicains la parole est à Antoine
fermerel marquez et on s'écoute s'il
vous plaît chers collègues monsieur le
Président chers collègues monsieur
vaserman nous décidons ce matin de
l'avenir du bras armé de l'État en
matière environnementale qu'il faut le
reconnaître à particulièrement briller
par son instabilité au cours des
dernières années comme le réclamait Yann
Arthus-Bertrand dans une tribunologie
Dédé il est temps de mettre fin à la
danse de l'intérim dont souffre la dame
et de nommer ce président dont une
organisation gouvernementale brouillonne
nous a privé au-delà des annonces
l'urgence est à l'action et dans ce
schéma l'ADEME est assurément un levier
puissant de l'action publique en matière
environnementale avec son budget et ses
quelques mille salariés équivalent en
plein monsieur vaserman sachez que le
fait d'avoir été des nôtres et donc de
bien connaître nos problématiques
parlementaires sera évidemment un atout
à nos yeux sachez aussi que nous avons
apprécié votre approche en amont de
votre candidature le précédent candidat
n'avait manifestement pas la même
méthode et la même considération pour
les parlementaires que nous sommes
notre commission jugera-t-elle
suffisante votre motivation et vos
aptitudes pour le poste l'ADEME mérite
un président à temps plein elle mérite
aussi un président sur le temps long
capable d'honorer son mandat de 5 ans
après la valse des intérim de vacances
et de démission qui a connu l'agence
quels seront vos chantiers prioritaires
à intégrer au prochain contrat
d'objectifs avec l'État quel rôle peut
jouer l'ADEME pour promouvoir et
généraliser des pratiques écologiques
vertueuses
incontestable d'un point de vue
scientifique nous garantirez-vous une
objectivité de l'expertise de l'agence
sur la question du nucléaire de la
consommation d'électricité des émissions
du secteur aérien nous garantirez-vous
une méthode et une considération
vis-à-vis des élus locaux l'ADEME est
parfois perçue comme éloignée des
préoccupations des plus petites
collectivités notre vœu au groupe des
Républicains et que l'ADEME reste une
agence de la transition écologique
consciente des attentes des Français et
dans l'action plutôt que dans
l'énonciation de grands principes et
c'est pour cette raison que le groupe
les républicains votera en faveur de
votre candidature
pour le groupe démocrate modem et
indépendant la parole est à Hubert hot
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues aujourd'hui
il nous revient à la responsabilité de
confirmer ou non
la proposition du chef de l'État confiée
de confier la présidence de l'ADEME à
Sylvain vaserman Sylvain vaserman est
indiscutablement un spécialiste des
sujets relatifs à l'énergie biométhane
réseau chaleur plan local de performance
énergétique sont parmi les mots clés
d'un bilan qui signe la réussite d'une
action avant-gardiste à la tête d'une
institution alsacienne qui l'a su
transformer si le hasard mal c'est aussi
un grand serviteur de l'État de l'élu
local jusqu'à la vice-président de notre
assemblée il y a toujours été guidé par
une indiscutable volonté d'agir si le
mazerman c'est le député qui a travers
sa Loi sur la protection des lanceurs
d'alerte votez à l'unanimité en première
lecture nous a rappelé la dimension
essentielle de toujours fédérer et de
garantir toutes les vigilances dès lors
qu'une inquiétude est fondée
j'ai évidemment la conviction que s'il
en vazerman est l'homme de la situation
mais je tiens aussi à rajouter que le
connaissant personnellement je peux
témoigner de ses qualités humaines de
rassembleur de fédérateurs
pour accomplir les missions qui seront
les siennes à la tête de l'ADEME ses
qualités personnelles seront un atout
majeur né en 1991 l'ADEME est plus que
jamais au cœur de l'actualité de par ses
missions c'est l'acteur de premier plan
face aux enjeux de notre époque l'ADEME
c'est l'outil par excellence de toutes
les convergences celui qui met en lien
l'État les entreprises les collectivités
et les citoyens pour faire face aux
dérèglement climatique qui nous
affectent et à la crise écologique que
nous subissons tous quand l'intérêt
général est en jeu ces liens sont
essentiels ils sont même incontournables
à l'heure de toutes les transitions nous
avons besoin d'expertise
d'accompagnement et surtout de proximité
c'est bien comme cela que nous
atteindrons nos objectifs et que nous
réduirons la fracture entre l'homme et
la planète
chers Sylvain même si vous avez anticipé
mes questions je voulais je voulais vous
poser la suivante comment
renforcerez-vous la place de l'ADEME
comme acteur de proximité dans la
transition et comment comptez-vous faire
mieux connaître cette précieuse
institution à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens il est évident que le groupe
modem va
très fortement vous soutenir et va voter
d'un seul homme pour votre candidature
merci pour ce suspense monsieur
pour le groupe socialiste et apparenté
la parole est à Stéphane de le traître
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues l'ADEME est une agence
technique pas comme les autres et vous
l'avez souligné monsieur vaserman son
expertise est connue et reconnue tant au
niveau national que local c'est pourquoi
nous attendons du nouveau président
qu'il renforce ses missions d'agence
experte au service de l'État mais
également auprès des entreprises et des
collectivités aussi ma première question
concerne les moyens humains et
financiers à louer à l'ADEME comme je
l'ai souligné en fin d'année dans mon
rapport budgétaire sur le programme 181
l'activité de l'ADEME a connu une très
forte croissance et accélération ces
dernières années et doit être accompagné
d'un recrutement recrutement de
personnels avec statut pérenne en effet
le recours à l'intérim trop systématique
et déstructurant pour la dame aussi pour
chaque personne avec ce statut par
ailleurs au regard de la priorité que
constitue les questions
environnementales il est impossible que
l'État fonctionne avec des contrats
d'intérim sur des missions aussi
stratégiques que la décarbonation ou
l'économie circulaire pourriez-vous nous
préciser comment vous envisagez de
mettre en place des actions pour y
remédier vous leur avez vous l'avez
rappelé ma seconde interrogation donc
portera sur la dimension territoriale la
force de l'ADEME repose aussi sur son
assise dans les territoires et sa
capacité à essaimer les projets mais
force est de constater qu'elle se
retrouve trop souvent en concurrence
avec d'autres agences comme BPI le
céréma la NCT aussi comment
envisagez-vous une meilleure
articulation entre ces dernières pour
conclure je voudrais rappeler que les
élus du groupe socialiste et apparentés
sont particulièrement attachés à l'ADEME
à son action dans nos territoires et aux
conditions de travail de ces agents
c'est pourquoi nous attendons des
réponses sans ambiguïté sur les points
que j'ai évoqués moyens financiers
effectifs et déclinaisons dans les
territoires je vous remercie
merci pour le groupe horizon et à
parenté la parole est à 20 centiibo
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur razerman chers collègues cela a
été dit l'edème est au cœur au cœur de
la politique de transition énergétique
au cœur de ces défis que nous devons
relever pour pour l'avenir pour l'avenir
des générations futures qui est la
transition énergétique l'ADEME
aujourd'hui c'est une expertise comme
vous l'avez évoqué dans l'accompagnement
dans la recherche de développement le
financement aussi de projet l'ADEME
aussi c'est un acteur incontournable
dans les territoires c'est vrai c'est
1200 opérateurs au sein de l'ADEME 4,2
milliards de de d'euros pour un budget
qui est en hausse constante mais c'est
aussi 1500 postes d'opérateurs qui sont
financés par l'ADEME et notamment dont
800 dans les collectivités territoriales
Sylvain votre tête votre expérience que
soit la tête de Taman d'une petite
commune mais aussi en tant que président
de gaz de de Strasbourg et aussi votre
connaissance
du compte de la construction de la loi
et des problématiques des parlementaires
sont pour nous en tout cas une véritable
richesse je tiens aussi à saluer vos
nombreux engagements que vous prenez
notamment dans le questionnaire transmis
point comme vous l'avez évoqué pour
annuel entre directeurs et genoux votre
tour de France et de retour de région
nous ne pouvons que nous en féliciter
toutefois je voudrais juste insister
nous voudrons switch insister sur ce
sujet à générer local vous l'a évoqué
effectivement c'est un point essentiel
on a pu constater aussi la problématique
de souvent des appels d'un projet qui
sont faits c'est souvent les meilleurs
élèves qui sont les premiers servis et
on met de côté au niveau du territoire
au niveau de la France un ensemble de
territoire qui n'ont pas l'ingénierie
suffisante pour pouvoir anticiper
effectivement ces projets et qui est
souvent sont dépourvus justement des
appels d'offres qui sont qui sont portés
par l'État ou notamment à travers
comment comptez-vous justement mieux
accompagner le territoire avec certaines
généricoles territoriales des
territoires qui souvent s'ignorent sinon
globalement vous avez toute notre
confiance et nous foutons favorablement
en tout cas pour votre nomination
merci pour le groupe écolo juste la
parole est à Nicolas Thierry merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur vaserman
la dermatégré sous la présidence de
François Mitterrand 30 ans d'existence
le périmètre d'action de l'ADEME c'est
peu à peu étoffé on peut cependant
regretter que ces effectifs et moyens
financiers ne soient toujours pas à la
hauteur des enjeux en effet face à
l'urgence climatique le gouvernement ont
trop souvent sous-estimé le rôle crucial
que la dame se doit de porter l'agence
acteur majeur de la transition
écologique doit donc devenir
l'établissement public incontournable de
cette non nature le pilotage de cette
Adam de cet agence et donc stratégique
pour notre pays existe des connaissances
spécifiques et une vision claire sur la
nécessité de réduire notre dépendance
aux endives fossiles cela passe par la
promotion du triptyque sobriété
efficacité énergétique et développement
des EnR or monsieur mazerman nous avait
dit vous avez dirigé une structure dans
l'objectif principal était la
distribution de gaz naturel j'aimerais
donc vous entendre sur ce basculement de
philosophie que vous allez devoir opérer
en passant d'une posture de distributeur
d'énergie fossile à une attitude
proactive pour promouvoir la sobriété et
la sortie des fossiles autre et dernière
question vous êtes à la tête d'une
société conseil et vous l'avez rappelé
dans vos propos liminaires je souhaitais
savoir si au delà d'arrêter les contrats
en cours vous pensez quitter la
direction de cette société conseil afin
d'éviter toute confusion merci pour vos
réponses
merci alors pour le groupe gauche
démocrateur républicaine je ne vois pas
Iberville France sur mon petit papier
mais rapidement
merci monsieur le Président très
rapidement une économie de propos comme
un autre habitude dans ce genre de
circonstances très simplement indiqué
que nous sommes tout à fait disposés à
prendre acte des engagements du candidat
en l'occurrence donc monsieur vanner
d'une part au regard
la mise en exergue de son engagement et
de sa sensibilité politique et pour nous
est un est un enjeu vis-à-vis de ce que
vous avez souligné à l'échelle des
territoires la nécessité effectivement
d'un lien majeur avec les énus
territoriaux en particulier des élus
locaux nous y sommes particulièrement
sensibles vous avez pris un certain
nombre d'engagement en urgence à ce
titre et nous sommes donc tout à fait en
phase avec ses engagements nous les
vérifions bien sûr
par ailleurs l'enjeu d'ingénierie nous
paraît effectivement majeur vous aurez
effectivement sur ce champ à déployer me
semble-t-il une énergie qui permette
effectivement de réunir les conditions
de l'assistance à projet qui est la
vôtre en conséquence de quoi
je suis mandaté par mon groupe pour
indiquer que nous voterons favorablement
H1 effectivement
à donner une stabilisation à long terme
à cette opérateur public merci
merci chers collègues et pour vérifier
justement ces engagements je vous
propose comment la fait notamment pour
la fit que nous puissions vous
auditionner tous les ans dans cette
commission pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire la
parole est agent le Brico merci monsieur
le Président salut notre rapporteur cher
David monsieur vaserman moi je partage
complètement votre avis sur sur le rôle
des territoires effectivement dans les
transitions durant pas je pense de
transition sans l'engagement
l'engagement des territoires évidemment
le rôle de la dame en matière de soutien
l'ingénierie à l'expertise vous le
verrez aux collectivités est
essentielles notamment pour les plus
petites qui ont souvent des des
problèmes pour aller chercher mobiliser
les compétences pour mettre en place ces
politiques quelquefois de mobilité
durable ou de réduction des déchets des
déchets par exemple donc quelle action
allez vous mettre en oeuvre pour
renforcer l'accompagnement de l'agence
auprès des plus petites collectivités
notamment en réalité je pense que votre
expérience dé devrait vous inspirer
c'est un côté plutôt rassurant un autre
sujet celui de la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments vous le savez on devra
massifier accélérer innovation notamment
les rénovations globales pour obtenir la
neutralité carbone pour 2050 l'été a mis
en place le programme faire faciliter
accompagné à former pour la rénovation
pour depuis rebaptiser France rénov en
collaboration notamment avec la dame
Lana et la Nil alors encore une fois
comment allez-vous améliorer les
synergies entre ces différents
opérateurs et j'ai évidemment été très
attentif à votre expérience en tant que
directeur général du réseau GDS et plus
particulièrement sur votre application
dans la création d'un des plus grands
réseaux de chaleur
l'enjeu des réseaux de chaleur je trouve
qu'il est essentiel pour créer en fin de
compte c'est dynamiques locales pour
créer ces dynamiques de massification
par quartier par par secteur je crois
que c'est extrêmement important donc
comment comptez-vous améliorer en fin de
compte ces synergies entre les
différents acteurs une dernière fois et
puis pour conclure notre goome peut
estime que vous expériences en tant quai
du local et national et votre intérêt
pour les problématiques liées à la
transition écologique seront vous être
utiles en tant que président de l'ADEME
vous noterons donc en faveur de votre
domination
merci chers collègues pour vos propos
monsieur Waterman je vais vous laisser
la parole pour répondre aux orateurs des
groupes
merci monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de re-balayer point par point
les sujets en étant pas trop longs
monsieur le Président c'est avec
évidemment grand plaisir que je
répondrai et que je solliciterai si vous
oubliez de me solliciter
si vous me faites cette confiance et si
vous ne choisissez il est évident qu'a
des engagements locaux que j'ai pu
prendre tout à l'heure
la présence du président de l'ADEME pour
rendre compte à cette commission est
évidemment essentielle mais ça ce sera à
votre main bien sûr
madame meignet milfer d'abord merci pour
ce point sur l'acceptabilité citoyenne
et le rapport aux citoyen effectivement
j'ai beaucoup écrit et travailler sur le
sujet des circuits courts entre les
citoyens et la décision publique qui les
concerne ce qui change profondément le
rôle de l'élu d'ailleurs je pense en
tout cas c'est la thèse que j'avançais
dans différents divers ouvrages mais je
crois que le sujet de l'acceptabilité
citoyenne de la transition écologique
est un véritable sujet est un véritable
sujet et que nous devons faire en sorte
de de ne pas fracturer en quelque sorte
ceux qui qui ont compris cette
importance la transition énergétique et
ce qui resterait à l'écart en baissant
les bras en disant de toute façon
ça me concerne pas c'est trop compliqué
ou j'ai peu d'impact donc vous mettez
l'accent alors j'ai pas de solution
miracle vous dans votre action vous avez
évidemment auprès des citoyens de votre
territoire une action déterminante mais
je crois en tout cas que cette
préoccupation et essentielle je vais
partager un point d'expérience je j'ai
suivi et participé à certaines réunions
de la CNDP dans son débat sur l'eau et
la qualité de l'eau le débat public sur
la qualité de l'eau n'avait jamais
existé je l'ai suivi pendant les six
derniers mois et on voit là aussi
qu'aujourd'hui les citoyens veulent
avoir leur mot à dire sur la qualité de
l'eau qui boivent ils veulent avoir leur
mot à dire sur les décisions publiques
qui les concernent donc beaucoup de
choses à mettre en place ce serait un
peu court j'avais modélisé plusieurs
modèles d'implication qui allaient
jusqu'à la co-construction je crois que
c'est voilà c'est en tout cas un sujet
sur lequel il faudra que je réfléchisse
à l'ADEME pour voir comment si vous
confiez cette mission je peux je peux
m'en faire les courses vous avez tout à
fait raison sur l'efficacité car le
risque serait de rentrer dans une
comptabilité de court terme je prends un
exemple que citais tout à l'heure sur la
géothermie aujourd'hui il me semble que
pour déployer cette de surface pour
cette déployer cette technologie et la
généraliser
il faudrait le point de local sont les
forages donc là c'est la filière qu'il
faut avec laquelle il faut travailler
donc évidemment c'est c'est de
l'investissement aussi du retour moyen
terme donc vous avez tout à fait raison
on doit pas être aveuglé par le court
terme malgré l'urgence puisque 2030
c'est très rapide on a 130 millions de
tonnes à trouver en d'ici 2030 donc il
faut à la fois concilier cette urgence
de la vitesse d'exécution sur ce qui
fonctionne quitte à aider des filières
et puis évidemment travailler sur
l'expérimentation de l'innovation qui
est qui est un point un point central
sur les agences de l'eau c'est dans l'un
de dans mon travail récent sur sur le
sujet que j'ai pu en mesurer
véritablement les enjeux ce que ce que
je n'avais pas eu à faire beaucoup sauf
en tant que élu local
dans mon parcours précédemment alors ce
serait peut-être un peu long d'élaboré
mais en tout cas
j'ai bien noté ce point là
Monsieur bléri Merci pour vos pour vos
propos
vous avez raison il faut bien distinguer
le l'aspect partisan de l'aspect
politique on est sur des sujets
politiques au sens noble du terme
après je crois que c'est mon mon
parcours j'ai été vice-président de
cette institution je crois qu'à aucun
moment on a on a vu dans mon
comportement de vice-président un aspect
qui serait partisan et tous les vices
présidents qui ont l'honneur de
vice-président de l'Assemblée savent que
leur rôle doit absolument quitter
quitter le rôle partisan donc évidemment
ça va sans dire mais je crois que c'est
mon parcours qui en atteste plus que les
propos j'ai envie de dire l'aspect un
peu banal des propos que je pourrais que
je pourrais citer aujourd'hui mais vous
avez raison moi je parlais beaucoup
d'alignement stratégique
de des acteurs avec les politiques
publiques c'était le cas quand je
pilotais quand je présidais une scène
une société économique ça doit être
en phase avec les politiques publiques
et chacun dans son rôle et chacun dans
son rôle c'est vous qui votez les
budgets c'est l'exécutif et vous qui
traitez
le rôle de l'ADEME je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est d'instruire et dans cet
objectif qui fasse qu'elle soit reconnue
qu'elle soit bien sur transpartisane
c'est une évidence mais qu'elles sont un
peu agnostiques c'est-à-dire peu importe
la vie que vous avez dans une démarche
scientifique de construction d'un
scénario et je me rendais compte que je
n'avais pas complètement répondu à l'une
des questions de monsieur le rapporteur
sur un scénario seul peut-il aboutir non
bien sûr il faut à mon sens
un juste chemin une juste ligne de crête
sur ces différents scénarios mais en
tout cas voilà je je
pense que c'est mon parcours qui
attestera de ce côté transpartisan plus
que tout propos que je pourrais tenir
monsieur Caron vous avez raison de poser
clairement la question est-ce qu'il
s'agit d'un recazage et dans ma vie
personnelle et et de mon comportement et
l'acceptabilité
sur sur
la question de qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait en réalité pour l'environnement si
je fais court dans votre mandat et dans
vos actions alors je vais pas parler des
amendements que j'ai pu porter je le
rappelle quand même moi j'ai toujours je
suis ingénieur de formation j'ai
toujours eu une approche assez
rationnelle des choses par exemple je
n'ai cessé et heureusement c'est
maintenant corrigé je n'ai cessé de dire
qu'on votait en tant que député donc là
je me place dans le mandat dernier on
votait des PPA avec des objectifs de
production de NR et quand on fait la
somme des objectifs qui figurent dans
les stradettes qui sont les documents
des régions qui pilotent ça la somme
elle colle pas avec ce qu'on va à Paris
ça et ça ne choquait personne
donc ça c'est un sujet que j'ai mis sur
la table dix fois comment peut-on vivre
avec un objectif national qu'on vote à
Paris et la somme des objectifs des
stradettes qui ne collent pas avec
l'objectif national ça c'est un exemple
de méthode alors évidemment moi je le
partais de ce prisme mais ça c'est un
sujet que j'ai beaucoup travaillé qui
maintenant est corrigé dans la loi
énergie puisqu'effectivement il y a un
dialogue qui doit avoir dans le respect
de la lit administration des régions
bien sûr mais il faut avoir ce dialogue
pour avoir une cohérence de ces
objectifs et pas être dans l'illusion de
quelque chose qu'on voterait sur les
bancs de l'Assemblée que au dernier
mandat
que que vous avez à voté avec un
décrochage ou un décalage par rapport
aux objectifs régionaux deuxième exemple
toujours dans cette logique là j'avais
travaillé sur les ceintures vertes il y
avait une espèce d'hypocrisie sur les
ceintures vertes je prenais l'exemple
que je connaissais bien à Strasbourg
pendant des années donc la ceinture
verte c'est ces zones autour de la ville
qui était des anciens glaces militaires
il y avait un dans la loi il se trouve
que c'était dans la loi par une
aberration enfin par une histoire
il y avait un taux de 20% mais personne
ne mesurait c'est 20% personne ne
rendait compte aux citoyens pour savoir
si c'est 20% maximum de construction
dans la ceinture verte était respectée
ou pas donc j'ai fait changer la loi
contre la vie des lieux locaux là pour
le coup pour dire on doit rendre compte
aux citoyens de la valeur de cette
mesure et le minimum qu'on a c'est
l'indicateur tous les ans alors
évidemment ça crée de l'instabilité
juridique parce que si on respecte pas
les 20% on peut être poursuivi pour ça
au tribunal administratif on peut être
rappelé à ses obligations mais je crois
qu'il faut sortir de ces sujets là alors
c'est des petits sujets le troisième
amendement que j'ai porté qui a été qui
a été qui a été
validé sur des thèmes très très ciblés
c'était aussi sur des mesures et des
indicateurs l'obligation pour les
grandes collectivités de publier leur
taux d'achat responsable
moi j'ai vu des cas ou des gymnases
étaient équipées d'équipements chinois
en dernier tour de table contre une
société française qui fabriquée en
France avec un petit delta de coups
c'est le choix souverain des élus très
bien mais je pense que la moindre des
choses c'est de rendre compte aux
citoyens quand on est dans une grande
métropole je parle pas d'un petit EPC de
rendre compte de la part d'achat
responsable c'est maintenant assez bien
cerné dans le droit ce que c'est qu'un
achat responsable et de mesurer la part
d'achat responsable de la collectivité
encore encore une fois dans le respect
profond des prérogatives des élus qui
décident mais je crois que vous rendre
compte donc ça c'est des entrées si mais
la chose majeure à mon avis à mon humble
avis que j'ai fait dans ma vie pour le
développement durable et pour l'écologie
j'en ai eu la confirmation il y a trois
semaines j'étais à une table ronde à la
Sorbonne j'ai eu le bonheur d'écrire une
loi et d'en être le rapporteur sur les
lanceurs d'alerte cette loi j'ai
travaillé aussi bien avec Monsieur
bernalisez qu'avec monsieur avec le
président Marleix qui à l'époque était
les deux personnes avec avec bien sûr
dans chaque groupe mais peut-être au
deux extrêmes de politique de
l'échiquier à l'époque en disant de
droite comme de gauche on avait des gens
impliqués dans cette démarche là cette
loi elle a été votée à l'unanimité en
première lecture à l'Assemblée parce que
Monsieur Marleix l'a soutenu parce que
monsieur bernaliste l'a soutenu et je
crois avoir trouvé cette Justine de
crête et à la Sorbonne il y a trois
semaines cette table ronde elle disait
l'environnement je pense qu'il y a un
deuxième thème c'est le droit du travail
et l'environnement de travail mais
l'environnement est un domaine sur
laquelle votre loi apportera des
avancées majeures parce qu'il y a un
sujet de il y a pas de victime vous
voyez une une flaque d'huile dans une
rivière et ben personne va au
commissariat porter plainte alors qu'en
réalité il y a une atteinte à
l'environnement et que l'alerte et la
culture de l'alerte et du signalement
dans l'environnement j'ai envie de dire
que c'est la brique que j'ai posé je
suis l'auteur de cette loi c'est une
proposition de loi qui après a été
programmée par le gouvernement sur le
temps parlementaire du gouvernement mais
c'est une proposition de loi dont j'ai
été l'auteur et le rapporteur et ça si
vous voulez une contribution concrète
dans mon mandat et dans mon application
d'élus c'est celle là que je mettrai en
avant et je soulignerai l'aspect
transpartisan et le travail que j'avais
pu avoir depuis comme je le disais
monsieur Bernay ici c'est Monsieur et
Monsieur Marleix
le point suivant je pourrais en parler
longtemps et moi je voilà Monsieur
Vermorel marquez merci pour vos propos
vous soulignez des points des points
majeurs
cette notion d'objectivité dans le
travail de l'ADM
je crois que je l'ai dit mais mais j'y
crois réellement il faut que chacun soit
sa juste place l'ADEME il est là pour
agir pour écouter pour ajuster pour agir
pour écouter ajuster agir dans le cas
des politiques publiques que vous
décidez que vous décidez
et il faut être respectueux de ça chacun
a sa juste place et ceux qui m'ont connu
dans mon mandat de parlementaire savent
le respect que j'ai pour cette
institution pour les parlementaires et
qui n'est pas fin et vous avez raison je
crois que chacun doit être à sa juste
place en tout cas si vous me confiez
cette responsabilité j'y serai vigilant
parce que je crois que le tiers de
confiance sur qui quel que soit votre
bord politique vous pouvez vous reposer
pour une étude sérieuse argumentée
construite qui envisage des scénarios
dans leur globalité et bien c'est un
point qui me semble essentiel pour la
pérennité de la dame et pour la relation
de confiance que vous pourrez avoir avec
la dame
monsieur hot merci pour vos pour vos
propos
j'ai répondu sur la partie loi lanceur
d'alerte l'enjeu de faire connaître nos
cultons pas le fait que tout ça c'est de
l'argent public que vous votez que vous
votez
et que et que du coup bien sûr le à la
fois la transparence sur ça c'est voilà
c'est le Parlement qui vote et c'est un
point qui me semble qui me semble
essentiel et je vais aller plus vite
parce que sinon monsieur delotrade
soyons très clair on m'a à de nombreuses
reprises je sais votre attachement pour
l'ADEME évidemment de votre parcours
personnel
je sais qu'il y a un sujet parce que
j'ai eu beaucoup depuis l'annonce de ma
proposition de candidature beaucoup déco
en ce sens
on manque de modélisation aujourd'hui je
les fais plusieurs fois dans ma carrière
de modéliser à partir des facteurs
dimensionnants les ressources
nécessaires certaines activités de
l'ADEME sont un peu des blocs de
compétences fixes vous avez pas besoin
d'augmenter le nombre d'experts en
géothermie ou en tel sujet en fonction
du nombre de projets géothermie en
France en revanche certains on peut
parler
de la partie de traitement des dossiers
par exemple ont un facteur
dimensionnement direct avec le flux je
crois à mon sens que d'abord on a alors
je sais pas s'il existe je ne sais pas
parce que évidemment je voilà c'est vous
qui déciderez si je peux aller
travailler sur ces sujets là mais je
suis pleinement conscient de ça et en
tout cas j'ai vu des alertes sur le
sujet je ne peux rien dire d'autre que
j'essaierai d'utiliser de convaincre sur
le fait que certaines activités encore
une fois ont un facteur dimensionnant
qui nécessite que quand on passe d'un
milliard à 4 milliards d'euros il y a
une logique qui n'est probablement pas
linéaire mais une logique de ressources
qui est absolument indispensable à
prendre à prendre en compte et puis sur
le la partie moi je crois que sur ce
sujet la boussole c'est la qualité des
femmes et des hommes et l'expertise des
adéniennes et des indémins comme on dit
qui ont une expertise reconnue
internationale allemande j'insiste sur
ça et ça c'est évidemment tous les
responsables d'organisation et
d'entreprises savent la difficulté à
recruter il serait absurde de laisser
de ne pas continuer à développer ce
vivier de compétences
à ce niveau de niveau de reconnaissance
qu'il peut avoir BPI séréma a NCT j'en
ai parlé et c'est un point majeur et là
j'ai pris un engagement clair sur le
sujet monsieur Thiébaut merci beaucoup
sur la partie PC
sur la partie des EPCI et du territoire
vous sachiez mon vous savez mon
attachement à ce sujet on a eu
l'occasion d'échanger à plusieurs
reprises sur le sur le sujet sur
l'ingénierie locale je réinsiste les
métropoles sont bien équipés pas les
EPCI et pas les réseaux d'assistance à
maîtrise d'ouvrage je l'ai vu sur les
contrats de performances énergétiques à
l'époque en tout cas les réseaux
d'assistance à maîtrise d'ouvrage
n'était pas au niveau pour accompagner
une petite collectivité sur un contrat
de performance énergétique à nous Adem
si vous me confiez cette mission de
travailler aussi à l'animation de ces
réseaux de maîtrise d'ouvrage qui sont
évidemment
au-delà de l'ingénierie directe qu'on
peut qu'on peut qu'on peut proposer qui
sont évidemment en prise directe sur ces
sujets là
Monsieur Thierry Monsieur Nicolas
Thierry j'ai vous vous souvenez un point
extrêmement important mais ce changement
de modèle
c'est peut-être pas été assez clair mais
non seulement je l'ai vécu mais je l'ai
initié je le redis depuis 150 ans cette
organisation faisait du gaz naturel et
que du gaz naturel quand j'en suis parti
30% et aujourd'hui 50% du chiffre
d'affaires et sur les réseaux de chaleur
sur le biométhane sur les contrats de
performance énergétiques donc j'ai
initié puisque j'ai créé j'en étais
directeur général j'ai créé cette
impulsion là je l'ai piloté c'est la
qualité des femmes et les hommes qui ont
permis de se dire mais finalement le
monde il peut pas être comme depuis 150
ans il évolue charge à nous en tant
qu'opérateur de l'énergie filiale d'une
collectivité acteurs de la transition
énergétique ça charge à nous de devenir
ce pôle de la transition énergétique
territoriale dédiée au territoire en
termes d'investissement d'innovation
donc ce changement et c'est extrêmement
merci de votre question merci de votre
question je n'ai pas dirigé une
entreprise de gaz pendant 9 ans j'ai
transformé une entreprise du monde
d'avant dans une entreprise un pôle
territorial de l'énergie est-ce que j'ai
fait là
l'industrie le vie et cette expérience
me sera utile quand je dialogue graisse
si vous me faites confiance et si vous
ne choisissez elle sera utile parce que
c'est le défi qui se pose à beaucoup
d'organisations beaucoup d'entreprises
donc merci de votre question je tenais à
être clair dans ma réponse pour vous
apporter tous les éléments
d'appréciation
monsieur Villefranche je vous remercie
[Musique]
il y a un tout un débat sur rénovation
versus décarbonation sur le bâti je vais
pas rentrer dans le fond de ce débat
mais vous l'évoquez en fait au travers
de votre question
[Musique]
je crois que ce qui est important c'est
cette culture du résultat qu'on doit
qu'on doit mettre en place et vous le
dites très justement un EPCI aujourd'hui
d'une taille comme j'ai pu piloter
comme de 10 000 personnes puis comme
vice-présente comme le 40 000 personnes
c'est des petites structures
et pour autant on a nos gymnase on a
nommeri on a nos bâtiments donc il faut
bien qu'on trouve des solutions et on
n'a pas l'expertise pour le faire je
crois aussi qu'on ne peut pas juste se
reposer sur des gens qui font ça pour
vous et je crois que l'ADEME doit être
se tire de confiance on parlait de du
soutien aux décisions publiques la
décision publique d'un acteur local pour
dire je rénove je fais un contrat de
performance énergétique puisque
maintenant les députés m'ont donné la
possibilité de le faire ou au contraire
j'investis dans du bâti ou au contraire
je décarbonate ma source d'énergie ces
sujets là nécessitent une ingénie je
j'ai vu le réseau des 700 personnes
financées par l'ADEME au coeur des
collectivités je crois que c'est un très
bon modèle sous réserve qu'on anime ce
réseau
que l'animation de ce réseau se fait
bien et je le dis parce que ce réseau
n'a de sens que s'il est animé en termes
d'expertise en termes de de liens en
fait entre entre l'expertise de l'ADEME
et le financement de personnes au sein
des collectivités qui doivent qui
doivent peut-être tous les ans deux fois
par an passé leur journée Adam puisque
finalement c'est l'ADEME qu'il est
subventionne et qui subventionne leur
poste pour pouvoir monter en compétences
suivre les évolutions et être au fait et
pouvoir porter ses changements au cœur
des collectivités
voilà je pense que j'ai fait le tour
alors j'aurais mille choses à dire
encore mais je vais en rester là si si
vous le voulez bien
peut-être alors je sais pas si j'ai été
clairement l'un ou l'autre point que je
n'ai pas tout à fait abordé je sais pas
si je vous en prie en sachant qu'il y a
encore des questions mais allez-y
allez-y peut-être un petit dernier mot
et apprendre enchaîne avec les questions
un dernier mot sur cette dimension
territoriale
ceux qui ont été élus local encore une
fois j'étais maire de village j'avais
quand même une administration de une
personne administrativement 800
personnes dans le village
président de PCI sur 5 5 villages après
sur une plus grande PCI
je crois que le sujet des collectivités
aujourd'hui dans cette ingénierie c'est
quels sont les modèles de confiance et
tiers de confiance et les modèles qu'on
peut avoir par exemple le cahier des
charges type sur le contrat de
performance énergétique qui peut
considérer deux trois bâtiments d'un
EPCI moyen pas les trucs hyper
sophistiqués mais le contrat de base ce
que fait d'ailleurs la fncccr dans
certains domaines
elle arrive avec des propositions un peu
standards que bien sûr chaque élu peut
s'approprier mais ça aujourd'hui ça
manque et ça je crois que c'est
extrêmement important dans notre
ingénierie de se dire bien sûr chaque
territoire est spécifique enfin un petit
EPCI il a d'abord le souci de faire
quelque chose de solide et
pouvoir avoir dans son dans sa besace
des éléments de confiance qui lui
permettent d'essayer de construire des
solutions solides et de pas tomber dans
dans certains travers ou certains
écueils qui sont donc l'ADEME un rôle
majeur à mon sens sur ça et ce sera si
vous me faites confiance si vous ne
choisissez ce sera dans mon rôle d'éveil
donc aux questions d'une minute la
parole est à Daniel brugois
le micro
monsieur vaserman on l'a compris vous
serez un président de l'ADEME qui va
rapprocher des députés à la fois la dame
national et la dame régionale et pour
nous ça nous sera précieux parce que ça
nous a beaucoup manqué concernant la
transition énergétique vous l'avez dit
elle se fera à partir des territoires
des petits territoires et c'est les
petits ruisseaux qui font les grandes
rivières et sans eux on y arrivera pas
donc les collectivités aujourd'hui ont
des enjeux majeurs qui est la rénovation
thermique de leur bâtiment quel rôle
l'ADEME
pourrait-elle jouer pour qu'ils y
arrivent
merci la parole est à Stéphane bichon
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
mesermann ravi de vous ravi de vous
retrouver
dans le fil de ce que vient de dire ma
collègue Daniel brûlebois reparler
effectivement du territoire et les
objectifs de neutralité carbone ont été
rappelés
et dans le cadre de ces objectifs
l'hydrogène doit prendre toute sa part
vous avez beaucoup parlé de l'Est de la
France on va
se déplacer de quelques kilomètres et
venir sur l'ouest et parler de la Vendée
ou l'entreprise Life et la première
entreprise productrice de d'hydrogène
vert il y a quelques jours le
l'entreprise a produit ses premiers
kilos d'hydrogène bleue à partir d'eau
de mer et devant du large à partir d'une
hydrolier d'une d'une éolienne flottante
ma question est très simple en fait
vous à la tête de l'ADEME
quelles ambitions porterez-vous pour
développer et pour accompagner
l'hydrogène merci beaucoup
la parole est à Laurence et del Grière
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur baserman ma question
concerne à nouveau les petites
collectivités locales et notamment la
relation que vous envisagez pour l'ADEME
avec ses plus petites d'entre elles
l'atteinte de nos objectifs climatiques
supposent que nous agissons tous la
suppose que chacun identifie les
priorités et celles sachent quelle
action mettre en œuvre si les
particuliers connaissent bien la dame
les élus locaux et tout particulièrement
des territoires ruraux on peut voir pas
du tout de relations avec l'ADEM aussi
quel est votre vision des relations que
l'ADEME pourrait bien bâtir avec les
petites collectivités rurales dans
l'accompagnant l'accompagnement à la
transition écologique à la sobriété
énergétique je vous remercie merci
oui je voudrais rebondir notamment sur
ce qui a été mis en avant par notre
collègue vers Morel marquez dans dans sa
question sur la manière dont
concrètement vous comptez embarquer les
plus petites collectivités dans ces
enjeux de transition écologiques la dame
a l'habitude de travailler avec les
communautés d'agglomération les
communautés urbaines les métropoles
comment est-ce qu'on s'adresse
spécifiquement et sur le plan du mode
d'intervention des directeurs régionaux
et aux communautés de communes les plus
petites parce que c'est souvent là que
la dernière marche à faire et les
travaux d'isolation sont les plus
importants sur les bâtiments publics
la parole est à Nicolas dragon
merci monsieur le Président du lésime
monsieur vaserman alors en premier lieu
je tenais à vous remercier à mon tour
pour la démarche et les prises de
contact individuel au sujet de votre
candidature que vous avez pu effectuer
bien souvent les députés se retrouvaient
le matin ici avec presque un fait
accompli l'exemple de votre prédécesseur
qui postulait à l'ADEME a démontrer le
contraire récemment et depuis donc à la
lecture de votre présentation à
l'audition de vos déclarations ce matin
il semblerait que le chemin qui pourrait
vous mener à cette présidence soit bien
engagée j'ai néanmoins une observation
c'est désormais selon les
recommandations même du GIEC que le pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique l'énergie nucléaire à toute
sa part elle est décarbonée et ce que
vous êtes favorable ou défavorable à
l'énergie nucléaire sachant que l'an
dernier un rapport de l'ADEME avait
laissé entendre qui remettait en cause
la pertinence de la relance du nucléaire
je vous remercie merci la parole de ta
Sylvie Ferrer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
vasserman j'ai consulté vos réponses aux
questionnaires qui vous a été envoyé
ainsi que votre lettre de motivation je
n'ai pas trouvé une fois le terme
sobriété c'est pourtant envolé
primordial dans le rapport transition
2050 publié par la dame l'agence que
vous souhaitez présider
à Cap Vert sur ma circonscription
l'ADEME finance à 50% un projet
d'agrives voltaïsme sur 55 hectares de
terre agricoles communales alors que des
alternatives existent sur du bâti à
Lannemezan l'ADEME a bon de 13 millions
d'euros la construction d'une chaudière
alimentée par des déchets tout ça pour
produire de l'hydrazine qui va finir
dans les centrales nucléaires ou des
produits phytosanitaires alors
voyez-vous je ne pense pas que le défi
immense soit le changement de mode de
vie l'accès à dignité citoyenne comme
vous l'écrivez dans vos réponses mais
plutôt le changement de mode de
production la sobriété donc pour
répondre à des besoins humains réels et
à partir de là vous verrez que les gens
accepteront la transition écologique
j'en viens à ma question que
comptez-vous faire pour que les
financements de l'ADEME alimentent de
véritables projets de transition
écologique et ne soit pas de simples
aubaines pour les multinationales je
vous remercie
merci la parole est à Aymeric
Caroni à ma question c'est pour ça que
je me permets de reprendre la parole
d'abord je vous félicite d'avoir porté
cette loi pour améliorer la protection
des lanceurs d'alerte mais vous
m'accorderez que c'était pas une loi qui
concerne spécifiquement les lanceurs
d'alerte sur l'écologie c'est plus
général j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
dire que notre groupe regrette les
attaques dont sont précisément
actuellement
victimes les lanceurs d'alerte
écologistes dans ce pays et je pense à
la dissolution des soulèvements de la
terre puisqu'il s'agit bien de lanceur
d'alerte dont le but est d'alerter
l'opinion sur des projets climaticides
cela étant dit je vous repose ma
question
à laquelle vous n'avez pas répondu quel
changement majeur préconisez-vous dans
notre modèle de société dans les
comportements de chacun pour lutter
contre le changement climatique c'est
très simple
merci la parole est à Nicolas
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
vaserman deux questions l'une a été déjà
évoquée mais je vais la reformuler vous
l'avez dit la transition écologique
passe par nos collectivités or comme
comment comptez-vous aider nos plus
petites collectivités qui ne sont pas
toujours armées en termes d'ingénierie
notamment pour bénéficier de toutes les
aides qui sont de plus en plus ciblées
je pense au fond vert bref quelle
démarche quel soutien technique concret
la dame peut établir avec nos
collectivités puis deuxième question au
vu de votre expérience et votre
expertise dans ce domaine je voudrais
avoir votre avis sur la politique de
suppression progressive des chaudières à
gaz même s'il faut bien sûr réduire
notre recours aux énergies fossiles
n'est-ce pas contradictoires avec la
volonté de garantir un mix énergétique
n'est-ce pas aussi hasardeuse de ne pas
miser
de ne pas vouloir tout miser sur le tout
électrique alors que la France dispose
d'un réseau de gaz parmi les plus
développés en fin n'est-ce pas le
contraire aussi à la volonté de
développer dans notre pays le BI ogaz
si la parole est à Gérard le seul
oui merci le Président c'est juste une
une question
monsieur le candidat vous savez que
l'ADEME a pu jeter un regard expert sur
les labels environnementaux il y a plus
d'une centaine de l'abeille il est
difficile pour le consommateur de s'y
retrouver en qui peut-on avoir confiance
donc il y a un vrai rôle d'expertise je
voudrais vous interroger sur ce sujet
précisément que pensez-vous des labels
que pensez-vous faire pour faciliter la
bonne lecture et la bonne compréhension
par les consommateurs des labels
environnementaux je vous remercie
la parole est à Nathalie Passière
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
vaserman j'aimerais souligner vos propos
vous parlementaire votez à Paris mais
une fine les projets naissent sur les
territoires ainsi que votre engagement
pour soutenir les innovations les
innovations territoriales et leur donner
tous leurs chances de devenir des
solutions robustes je ne peux que les
partager d'autant plus que les
territoires tamarins sont des zones non
interconnectées telles la Réunion qui
avait validé sa BPE l'ADEM il y a un
rôle déterminant bien sûr en matière
d'énergie et les scénarios de l'ADEME
sont très ambitieux pour le
développement des énergies renouvelables
sur nos territoires et il est essentiel
que la dame travaille en concertation
avec les élus et les opérateurs locaux
juste un exemple la dame avait prévu un
scénario de 1000 mégawatts de PV pour
atteindre 100% d'énergie renouvelable
alors que la PPE de la Réunion a validé
500 MW alors vous voyez combien ce
manque de concertation pénalise
notre trajectoire si la creux suivait
bien sûr cette proposition
vous conviendrait qui nous faut
aujourd'hui coordonner les différentes
études pour un gain de temps pour un
gain de finance et permettre vraiment à
nos territoires de profiter
pleinement de cette de cette organisme
alors pour être est-ce que vous engagez
à travailler bien sûr avec tout le monde
et je pense et je pense également à
Mayotte où il y a un retard en termes de
transition énergétique à rattraper je
vous remercie
merci est-ce que d'autres collègues
souhaitent prendre la parole
personne monsieur
lazerman je vous laisse le soin de
répondre merci beaucoup mesdames et
messieurs pour les questions riches je
vais essayer d'en regrouper certaines
parce qu'elle était thématiques un peu
transverses essentielle que vous que
vous soulevez
essayer de répondre diverses questions
qu'il y a eu sur la partie collectivité
territoriale de petite taille
moi je pense que pour parler extrêmement
concrètement il y a plusieurs choses qui
sont directement à faire d'abord je
crois qu'il y a un dialogue avec les
représentants l'association des mers
ruraux de France de l'association qui
représente les EPCI parce que elle joue
un rôle important dans la diffusion des
sujets et dans leur présentation de ces
collectivités évidemment les 36000
communes donc on voit l'importance de de
d'essayer d'avoir des relais par rapport
par rapport à la fois pour remonter les
attentes et à la fois pour déployer les
solutions dans les solutions extrêmement
concrètes moi je crois je crois au
cahier des charges type au travail
d'ingénierie Hamon qui puisse être
largement diffusé après approprié par le
territoire pour les spécificités qu'il
peut avoir mais je crois à cette à ce
travail en amont qui permettra à un élu
de rentrer dans un chemin assez balisé
et éviter des écueils
ou des ou des thématiques complexes qui
n'a évidemment pas la possibilité de de
connaître lui-même
ou de s'entourer par une administration
qui puisse le faire
donc cette notion de cahier des charges
type et puis troisième point alors je le
redis le la mission des directeurs
régionaux c'est avant tout ça c'est
avant tout d'être en proximité alors
peut-être faut-il je n'ai pas rencontré
de directeur régionaux sauf ceux que je
connaissais de l'époque où j'avais
travaillé avec eux donc j'ai vu un peu
leur rôle mais du côté acteur des
réseaux de chaleur donc c'est un rôle
différent du rôle du rôle de d'un acteur
mais je pense c'est un dialogue que je
dois avoir très vite avec eux pour
savoir comment être une force de soutien
par rapport à ses collectivités j'ai pas
de réponse toute faite en tout cas j'ai
la conviction encore une fois que petit
1 les associations d'élus petit 2 les
cahiers des charges un peu standardisés
et qui balise les chemins et petits
trois le dialogue direct avec les
directeurs régionaux au service des
territoires et des élus quel que soit la
taille de leurs collectivité en
particulier évidemment plus la
collectivité est petite plus le sujet
est important parce que moins il a de
ressources et de moyens pour pour mettre
en œuvre les solutions
donc ça ça recoupe plusieurs questions
qui m'avaient été posées sur le sujet
sur le point de l'hydrogène
alors il se trouve que j'avais étudié le
sujet de l'hydrogène parce que c'était
souvent présenté si vous l'avenir du gaz
et comme ça je peux répondre à cette
question l'avenir du gaz une question
qui se pose la force des réseaux de gaz
aujourd'hui c'est diriger le territoire
les réseaux de gaz irriguent le
territoire il serait fou de se dire que
c'est actif sur lequel tout le monde a
investi soit mis à la poubelle le
biométhane l'hydrogène sont des pistes à
creuser sur dans ce domaine là alors
voilà depuis les dernières années je
n'ai pas vu l'évolution je ne savais pas
par exemple que sur l'hydrogène vert
hydrogène bleue en l'occurrence on a les
avancées aussi rapidement il y a des
expérimentations que j'ai suivi sur
l'hydrogène mais je pense que là il y a
alors voilà je vais répondre en humilité
que je préférais me plonger dans le
dossier avant de vous répondre mais
évidemment l'hydrogène fait partie des
solutions
moi je comprends que le modèle
économique n'arrive pas à percer il y a
une expérimentation en ce moment à
Strasbourg et que le modèle économique
est difficile c'est là où la puissance
publique a un rôle à jouer
si tout était simple avec un modèle
économique qui s'imposait donc là avoir
si la filière peut être structurée si
l'aide peut-être
sur le même cas que tout à l'heure sur
les Foreurs sur la géothermie il y a
peut-être un investissement à faire sur
la filière qui permette de façon plus
générique d'aider l'ensemble des acteurs
sans avoir évidemment la subvention à
chaque cas qui qui qui probablement ne
prendrait pas ne ferez pas de sens
monsieur le seul vous parlez des des
labels alors
vous n'avez peut-être pas lu l'ouvrage
que j'ai écrit en 2020 sur le sujet mais
notamment où je recommande et mon point
je recommandais à l'époque les causes
corps alors ça s'appelle maintenant
plutôt planète score en fait je trouvais
aberrant qu'on ne m'aide pas le
consommateur dans on parle toujours du
consommateur et ça on le met pas dans la
situation de prendre sa décision parce
que quand vous achetez quelque chose en
réalité vous connaissez pas du tout
l'impact qu'il a sur le climat et si on
vous le disait vous pourriez faire un
choix éclairé donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ne met pas le
consommateur quand il est dans son
supermarché avec les éléments en main
alors il y a des Yuka il y a d'autres
acteurs de ONG qui prennent ce relais
enfin on devrait on doit le mettre en
situation de même qu'il a son
nutri-score qui doit généraliser il faut
un ecoscor systématique et en tout cas
c'est ce que je préconisais en 2020 dans
l'ouvrage qui s'appelle le monde de
demain le monde d'après commence demain
matin pardon et je pense que ça c'est un
point alors c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
débats sur le sujet en ce moment il y a
beaucoup d'action aussi sur le sujet
voilà donc moi pour le coup comme je
l'ai écrit je vous dis que je suis non
seulement extrêmement favorable que la
clé c'est la méthode que la clé ça la
méthode que la dame a beaucoup apporté
sur la méthode comme dans beaucoup de
sujets il y a tout un sujet sur les
plastiques aujourd'hui on a pas parlé
consigne ou pas consignes c'est des
sujets extrêmement importants sur lequel
l'ADEME a tout son rôle à jouer
d'expertise et d'accompagnement parce
qu'une fois qu'on a dit on met un score
évidemment il faut que la méthodologie
soit une attaquable il faut qu'on puisse
avoir
des éléments qui prennent en compte à la
fois le carbone des pensées pour le
produire le carbone dépensé pour
l'amener jusqu'au rayon et avoir une
vision un peu globale en tout cas pour
moi la clé c'est mettre le consommateur
en situation de décider honnêtement de
s'il veut ou pas prendre telle ou tel ou
tel élément monsieur Carron je vais pas
me défausser sur la question à laquelle
je n'ai pas répondu dans mon
comportement personnel alors moi j'ai
des filles donc on discute gel sont
elles sont à l'âge ou cette génération a
eu un rôle majeur pour éveiller les
consciences et du quotidien et bien je
vais vous répondre quelque chose que je
leur répondais en échangeait là-dessus
je vais pas parler de ma vie privée ici
mais
chacun doit faire un effort on parlait
des moyens de production et des
comportements moi je pense que chacun
doit s'interroger sur ses pratiques et
j'interrogeais aussi sur la place du
numérique dans la transition énergétique
aujourd'hui le numérique alors on lit
beaucoup d'études là-dessus je suis
impatient de voir les d'échanger avec
les experts de la dame mais enfin
il faut moins prendre l'avion peut-être
probablement voilà changer ses habitudes
il faut aussi
il faut il faut moi manger de viande non
mais ça c'est personnel moi j'en mange
moins mais c'est personnel et je vais
sûrement pas dire aux gens ce qu'il doit
faire dans leur vie mais en tout cas je
pense que chacun doit avoir une
restriction et non non je vais pas dire
à chacun ce qu'il doit faire dans sa vie
non je suis désolé moi je reste dans mon
rôle je reste dans mon rôle je partage
mon expérience et tout en tout cas en
tout cas en tout cas en tout cas je ne
me sens pas du tout d'expliquer
d'expliquer à chacun ce qu'il doit faire
et je reste à ma juste place en tant que
candidat et en revanche ça veut dire
aussi qu'il faut demander à un jeune
dans sa sensibilité est-ce qu'il a
arrêté son abonnement Netflix et ce qui
regarde un peu moins de streaming parce
que la sobriété elle concerne aussi le
numérique et c'est un sujet maintenant
excusez-moi non non mec c'est moi je
réponds personnellement si vous plaît
s'il vous plaît je réponds personnel et
ma posture ce ne sera pas dire aux gens
ce qu'il doit faire mais je pense que
chacun mais non non non non non non non
non et je pense que chacun doit avoir
cette réflexion personnelle et que
chacun
sur la transition énergétique chacun a
sa part à prendre que ce soit le monde
économique que ce soit les décideurs
publics que vous êtes que ce soit chaque
citoyen voilà en tout cas c'est c'est
pas dans mon rôle de dire ce qui doit
faire quoi et je répondrai un peu pareil
sur le sujet là
moi je voudrais que si vous me faites
confiance si je suis à la présence de
l'ADEME je voudrais qu'en fait vous vous
disiez en fait peu importe la vie du
président de l'ADEME sur telle ou tel
sujet parce que parce que je voudrais
pas qu'on dise ah bah lui il est
pronucléaires ont-ils nucléaire lui il
est trop machin ou anti machin lui il
est provient de anti viande c'est pas le
sujet je dois rester à ma juste place en
tant candidat c'est vous qui décidez si
on doit réglementer ou pas telle ou tel
sujet c'est vous qui donnerez des
possibilités budgétaires à la dame pour
le faire ou pas moi ce que je dois
garantir c'est que l'étude qui vous
parviendra quand vous aurez un sujet en
tant que parlementaire quand vous vous
interrogez sur un amendement quand vous
interrogez sur un texte de loi ce que je
dois garantir c'est que cette étude elle
soit objective elle est regarde un peu à
360 degrés les enjeux complexes d'une
décision
le débat sur le plastique en ce moment
est très intéressant c'est la décision
est compliquée j'ai été président de PCI
je sais qu'on peut pas juste tout
changer comme ça et en même temps et en
même temps on est loin des objectifs il
faut agir donc ces sujets là sont
compliqués notre rôle à l'ADEM si vous
me faites confiance si vous choisissez
ce sera de faire en sorte que vous
puissiez dire l'ADEME elle est là comme
tire de confiance elle nous éclaire et
après nous on prend nos décisions donc
je voilà voilà en tout cas la
philosophie que je voudrais déployer et
je crois avoir fait le tour je dois
m'arrêter j'espère avoir répondu à la
majeure partie des questions je m'en
excuse s'il y en a qui n'est pas pu
abordé mais je voudrais dire une
dernière chose merci pour les pour les
les messages de soutien que vous m'avez
donné moi je pense et j'y crois en
disant je pense deux choses la première
c'est que la dame doit être
transpartisane et que évidemment
évidemment je postule et je souhaite
être élu mais je souhaite être élu
largement par un parlement qui se dit
l'ADEME c'est un outil tout autant du
Parlement que de l'exécutif et qu'on
s'approprie cette réunion cette relation
pardon entre les parlementaires et la
dame c'est un objectif que je porterai
si vous faites confiance je crois que
votre vote sera un message et que
en tout cas moi je
sollicite qu'on est le plus large
consensus possible non pas seulement sur
ma personne mais sur l'ADEME et le fait
qu'elle porte un rôle important par
rapport au Parlement et deuxième chose
dernière chose c'est ma dernière
conclusion
je voudrais terminer avec ce message
d'espoir que je donnais tout à l'heure
les solutions existent des solutions
nouvelles s'invente tous les jours le
rôle de l'ADEME c'est d'agir de
généraliser de déployer d'être l'acteur
efficace dans ce déploiement dans cette
messe que certains appellent la
massification en tout cas la
généralisation de ce qui marche on a des
enjeux importants là-dessus le deuxième
c'est d'accompagner cette innovation et
cette expertise qui est si nécessaire
dans ce domaine là merci pour votre
écoute mesdames et messieurs merci
Monsieur vaserman un peu d'attention
il est d'usage de laisser la possibilité
attendez attendez il est d'usage aussi
de laisser la parole à notre rapporteur
pour un mot de conclusion sur le
rapporteur
juste dire oui je remercie Monsieur
vasarelle pour sa disponibilité d'un
chers collègue s'il vous plaît la phase
d'audition préalable s'il vous plaît
puisque nous avions l'occasion de
discuter lors d'une audition et des
réponses que vous avez apportées je
pense que mes collègues députés sont
pleinement éclairées par vos réponses et
vos interventions d'aujourd'hui pour
pour faire le choix voilà donc on
redonne un peu un président à l'ADEME
merci monsieur le rapporteur merci pour
votre travail monsieur fauzerman on vous
laisse donc le soin de quitter notre
salle merci pour les réponses
apportées merci beaucoup à très vite